well
the most okay so if you're analysts okay
i always tell my analysts i only need
two things from you and if you want to
be analysts and you need to be analysts
of course before you become a good
investor
you want to provide accurate and
complete information
accurate and complete
most people failed on both score big
time
and you just have to go to that extra
length in order to get it done
if you can't succeed on that one you can
succeed succeed in this business
because most of the time you're gonna
stand alone
basically again it's just about
everybody else
and if you're not really confident about
what you know
and you're confident about your
prediction what other people know or
don't know
you can't possibly
be putting that kind of a money when the
things going into a free fall
when it looks like you're really losing
all your money when everybody else is
laughing at you
all the smart guys
so you must be able to first to do
accurate and complete
and the second thing
in this business okay
most money are not made on those stocks
i was just talking about
your biggest amount of money you're
gonna ever make is not from that
those are things really get your brand
and get your basic business going give
you the basic returns
they do not provide you upsize return
even if both stock went up five six
times they do not give you
the outsize returns
if you're a value investor in the truest
sense okay so there are two schools i
mean you can do the treaty bronze you
can do the main grams
or you can do the buff and longer type
which is
more of kind of what i interested in if
you want to be that one your return is
going to come from
a hundred no more than no more than
number on the two hand your entire life
of maybe 50 years
of tremendous insight
tremendous insight you're going to a
game that no other people have
how do you really build that insight
there's no other way other than
basically continuous curiosity intense
curiosity continuous study for your
whole life
anything that
works i was asking you is in your
career yeah doing this kind of analysis
what particular mistakes did you make do
you remember well i every time i failed
all those three scores i made a mistake
every time i didn't really get accurate
information i made a mistake complete
information made a mistake i did not i
thought i have an insight it wasn't
inside i made a mistake every time i
followed all three scores i made a
mistake and there are plenty
well
on the big bet i ever made
i
i don't recall we ever made a mistake i
shot on the big bed
now
my biggest mistake actually
is not making a couple bet
biggest mistake i made hello guys thanks
for watching the video now first i will
share with you my notes and then some
personal reflections
so how to be a good business analyst
well ilu says you have to
be accurate and complete
why because you gotta have conviction
when everybody else is laughing at you
and it looks like you're losing all your
money
and in order to make those concentrated
bets
you need to have
done the complete research and have all
the accurate figures
for the real outsizer returns you gotta
have an insight that the market doesn't
have
you will may have only five to ten
insights for all your life
and this is what differentiates the gram
model
which is to search the so-called cigar
bots
and
take the liquidation value of those
with the
buffett monger model which is to hunt
for the great businesses
which you would buy
at a fair price
or even better at a cheap price if you
can find it
now to gather those insights i believe
you have to be a learning machine driven
by curiosity
now what i love about the buffett monger
model is that it's tax efficient it
works like a tax deferred account
because you don't pay on the accumulated
capital gains
and you delegate the compounding to the
company
that's why these businesses are also
called the compounders
the compounders share in common that
they are run by talented capital
locators and the business enjoys a mode
with the ability to invest back into the
mode for a long time for me personally a
great example of a compounder is wix.com
they are highly vertically integrated
which makes very makes it very difficult
for the companies to replicate their
operations and assets
and they also enjoy strong switching
costs given the pain
and effort
to change from one web builder to
another this company also have
big reinvestment opportunities as the
total threshold market is calculated at
190 billion dollars
while week's market cap is still at 11
billion as of august 2021
okay guys that was all for today
thanks again for watching the video and
if you found the content valuable
please subscribe and give us a thumbs up
to hopefully reach other people like
minded
[Music]